how did it be a bug
I feel bub
[Music]
it's fake it's not
it's not real
hey guys so we're back talking about the
Wolverine as we promised in our review
for the Man of Steel we were going to
come back I was gonna bring Sam back
again for another spoiler review I just
took her to see the Wolverine and we're
gonna start talking about it and really
quickly a spoiler warning because this
is a spoiler filled review we're gonna
talk about all different types of things
that are in this movie beginning middle
and especially the end particularly the
end credits so overall how do you feel
about Wolverine and Hugh Jackman's
glorious body glorious body part was
delicious and it was a great film I
think I had a little bit of a problem
focusing on and a couple scenes about
what was going on
so did I actually I won't lie he's
attractive man he's naked for half this
film he's a good-looking man
so the Wolverine opens with this really
intense scene you're in Nagasaki the
bomb drops when they showed that shot
though of Hugh Jackman's body just
completely burnt to hell I was like oh
wow that's actually kind of badass and
that's kind of set the tone for the
movie because that opening were each of
the Warriors we're committing suicide
really set the tone for a more serious
and kind of close to yeah a little bit
more gruesome of a comic book film I
don't really view this as your typical
comic book movie it was a little more
serious minded I don't know I actually
would have pg-13 when I was watching it
the body count is very high in this
movie and you see the body count unlike
in a couple films right you don't see
the deaths you just hear about them you
actually see like the bodies dropping in
a couple places you see the blood I know
blood on his clothes yeah I'm not so
sure it's good for younger kids
oh no no no Wolverines a killer yeah
bring the killer and they got that part
really good Don Patton this movie I love
the fact that they really depicted him
as that hardened badass that he is in
the comics cuz I liked him in the first
few movies they made him a more frenzied
character yeah he was too he was just
more not just his physical
transformation for his body he was he
was bigger he was more veiny more tight
and everything but his character as a
person was more torn more emotionally
damaged I liked how it opened and it
showed him that he's not the Wolverine
anymore he's like that's not who I am
anymore and you really get to see the
progression of how not only he forgets
about Jean Grey and and moves on with
another woman but that scene where he
fights Shingen with a sword and he's
like what
the monster are you he's like the
Wolverine he pulls that sword out of him
oh my god that scene gave me chills I
swear it was beautiful Hey oh sure I
like to the particular scene where they
completely sliced through his body yeah
how did his sword cut through his an
immense ium spine is marvelous that's
actually true there's a and that's one
of the big fan complaints I've heard
about this movie
I take fan complaints with a grain of
salt for one reason I know that you
can't adapt everything perfectly I will
give him this they do go a little far
with adamantium stuff for one I read
that in the comics silver samurai can't
actually cut through his claws but he
does in the movie the whole adamantium
spine probably wouldn't get cut all the
way through with a sword either a normal
traditional samurai sword probably
wouldn't have cut through an immense
yeah not at all people can get a little
nitpicky sometimes you're gonna have
some yeah issues with the entire film is
an entirety one of the things that a lot
of fans have said is that the whole
reveal at silver samurai is actually the
Yoshida guy from the beginning is like
well he's not that's not who he is in
the comics that's not how it was in the
comic see there are certain things I
understand there are liberties to be
taken with characters from time to time
that'll happen in an adaptation it's it
can't be perfect it's not gonna be to me
the best way that you can adapt a comic
to a film is if you capture the tone and
the feel of the characters and the
setting in the location if you can sell
that tone and feel as best as you can
while taking some liberties I'm fine
with that and there's a few liberties
that are taken it didn't take me out of
the movie though no it doesn't take you
out of the film it still as a whole good
film it doesn't completely eradicate the
character of the samurai but I still
really enjoyed seeing it actually fit
the film it did that's the thing it fit
the film to ever make yeah I fit the
film they were making his bodyguard the
redhead check you know the first few
scenes are I was like is she gonna
really suck at acting well the first
time I saw it but then I like really
started to get into her and she actually
your performance is pretty good like the
scene where Logan had to cut into
himself to get that spider bot thing out
of him and she was like crying she's
like Logan you're going to die like I
don't know he's just I was I was kind of
attached to that scene I liked it I
liked her character it was a strongly
developed character they gave her a
backstory they gave her kind of the
reason she is now without telling too
much of her story she bastard yeah she
kicked ass and you can tell was a lot of
actually her doing the stunts and a
little less of the CGI which I
appreciated about this film was a lot of
it it's actually things that could
almost completely be done in real life
there was a couple scenes that were a
little bit obviously altered but for the
most part it was a lot of actual people
doing real stunt work right and that
makes me happy because people doing
stunt work is starting to become a lost
art form and I love people actually
doing real martial arts real practice
skills because it's almost starting to
turn into a dying art form which is very
very very depressing for me I completely
agree with you that's one of my favorite
things about this movie the way James
Mangold directed it and I just want to
say James Mangold actually thanked me
for my original review on Twitter and if
I ain't weird chance he watches this
that's awesome dude you did a really
good job it was a really well directed
it was it was good the shots were
beautiful
Hugh Jackman in this movie is - he is
we'll bring at this point to me I can't
really envision someone else playing
this role no I I think he's only gonna
have a couple more films in him but I
just think he's so good he is the main
x-men that everybody's looking for
in these films and yeah that Easter egg
at the end with Trask industries on the
TV and you get Professor X and Magneto
in their sets up Days of Future past a
huge audience response at the screening
that I went to they they ripped roared
they were very happy about that things
about this movie I really liked the
romantic relationship I actually thought
was strong and a few people told me they
were like Chris I don't really
understand the importance of the
romantic relationship it's to help
Hammond yeah it gets the past out of him
yeah you know the whole Jean Grey soul
of Jean and making him realize I still
have things I can live for exactly
actually genuinely falls in love with
this girl over a very short amount of
time when he wants to protect her it
wasn't right I don't know if he fell in
love like I feel like he just felt he
was able to feel a connection again yeah
he felt the connection again to two
people I just wanted to like he kind of
sees the other one almost kind
history tourism let's wait use like
don't touch my friends right don't what
do you think don't hit my friends yeah
don't hit my dog my friends yeah so he
I'm gonna say that the people whatever
if someone ever hits my friends I'm
gonna sprout claws don't hit my friends
what do they hear me
well then I'll kill him it won't be any
there won't be any talking I will just
be death I'll probably hit back first
instant death
yeah well both it overall I felt that
the Wolverine from start to finish for
the most part was a pretty consistent
movie except for the last 20 minutes and
the inclusion of the character of VIPRE
the blonde chick I didn't really think
she was a strong villain I should have
realized that she was coming though I
really should have especially with that
bear scene at the beginning he kind of
brings up the honor thing again and you
should have gone after that bear instead
of poisoning in it cuz that's obviously
why that people got killed which by the
way that was pretty awesome in that bar
he just sticks it in the guy's hand he's
like ask me where I found it and he's
like where'd you find it he's like funny
you should ask
burning out into an open wound see
that's what I mean to me that is well
even though he said he wasn't the
character of Wolverine in that scene he
when he became Wolverine after the shin
gun fight again it was kind of like in
Dark Knight Rises when Bruce Wayne
climbed out of the pit and he and you've
got the Batman theme for the first time
I really dug Wolverine the last 20
minutes got a little comic book ish for
me but I'm gonna go with my original a -
great I really like the movie I'm still
a little bit leery of how they sliced
off his claws with a hot an immense ium
sword it wasn't in the comics that way I
can deal with it because it made it more
intense yeah it made it more like oh
like Wolverine we're just getting
hurt but I get it it worked for the
movie but overall I gave this film the
storyline I gave a B+ and the directing
I'm gonna give probably an a like I like
the scenes I like the shots I liked the
clothes that they put some of the more
intricate details paid attention to the
culture where they were add a little bit
more them to be matinee and the story a
b-plus
one of the things I didn't mention and
actually was how much I loved the
Japanese culture and you and I both
really liked the Asian culture and so
that kind of added to it for us too
because it was cool too I like in movies
where people who are Japanese actually
speak Japanese like I'm trying to but
you're American right not everyone is
always speaking English when they're in
their private quarters filled with
Japanese people they're probably gonna
speak Japanese which I liked about this
and I actually understood everything
that they were saying that's from whole
the anime there's no the anyway I
watched that's true I have actually
gotten to the point where I don't really
have to look at the subtitles anymore to
know what's being said in the anime
pretty impressive so guys what did you
think of Wolverine we both enjoyed the
film we're gonna come back in a few
weeks or so we'll pick another movie
coming out soon and maybe kick ass two
or four and we'll do definitely Thor for
sure we'll do a no spoiler review maybe
do a Halloween video get some surprises
at the Halloween video yeah we thought
about doing some scary movie reviews
later in October just for like a fun I
didn't see anything in the lineup worse
it's like a fun themed thing yeah thanks
again for joining me Sam and as always
guys if you did like this review then
you can click right here and get hmm
what are you doing hmm are you gonna say
it even me see it yeah I get stuck when
I just go get stuck nice
you even come back to that at that
little spot egg little easter egg yeah
the little easter egg at the end of the
film where there you have Magneto and
Professor back yeah that was pretty
awesome and that sets up the next track
being on the screen Trask
Trask yeah yeah I can't pronounce things
anymore you even get that little Easter
egg at the end Professor X and Magneto
kind of meeting him at the airport two
years later and you see tracks how about
I say it how about I say yeah one of the
things I really liked which you had your
head buried in my shoulder for most of
this scene was how intense they made the
scene where Logan digs that thing out of
him I was like wow like this is awesome
like I don't know like I really loved
that because it was so you were yes you
were she doesn't remember she was
traumatized travel-time
no I watched him dig his hand into
himself and you got to watch it on the
computer yeah in the fang region and
like try to grab that thing about this I
was not okay I feel better with blood
than you do that's not true let's go
watch only God forgives let's go watch
it I'm serious
think about the i cutting scene and the
ears stabbing scene okay I can deal with
the ear separately needles are sharp
instruments going towards eyes can I do
that sorry I will completely walk away
[Music]